[Music]
there are
certain tournaments in esports that will
change your life if you win
the lpl has never won before but that
will change today
the groundless are finally king and
invictus gaming
are your 2018 world champions
all this happens they made and work
clown
nine are your alien major champions
arsene is your evil japan champion
whether you fought through blood sweat
and b.o at evo
clapped faker at worlds or finally lived
up to your major sticker
esports has grown to the point where a
world championship
won't just earn you a sense of spiritual
fulfillment
but a financial one as well three
million
dollars richer the biggest
individual prize victory in competitive
gaming history and nowhere is this
sentiment truer than at ti from having
your name etched onto the aegis
to claiming the lion's share of a
bajillion dollar prize pool
there's nothing like watching someone's
life change as they knock down the last
tick of health
on that final fateful ancient they're
gonna do it
they're gonna change the alliance wins
they win
ti3 but of all the demigods ever to make
dota's
ultimate ascension none have undergone
as much of a transformation
as to pius thompson tavit simon the
finnish mid lane god of dota's greatest
ever team
winning his first ti wasn't just an
incredible achievement
and one of esports greatest underdog
stories
it was a turning point you see somehow
in the matter of two weeks
and one historic aegis lift this guy
began a metamorphosis he went from being
a
virtual nobody to an all-worshipped
god can he keep this man alive though he
doesn't have the blacktop backup you
have a banana with a big gust sending
him back
tornado thompson he's in the back of the
beach coming down thompson
with the save for them
so how exactly did this unknown pub star
turn in-game confidence into real-life
swagger
and what is the secret sauce that caused
the meek topson
to become chadsin the most successful ti
participant of all time thompson he just
does not give a crap
anna will give all the life this is just
fountain farming
okay so to understand how our boy went
from this
topson to the tops and she told you not
to worry about
we have to go back back to the months
preceding ti-8
when he was just an unknown unassuming
pub star
but all of that changed in an instant
i got a message from jerax that
og is in is looking for new players and
i was one of the people they were
looking at and then i was like
in a disbelief that i would be
able to play for og most of you may
probably know the story by now
following the anime grade betrayal they
suffered at the hands of fly
og couldn't find any top tier trouncers
to stuff into their mid lane so with
only eight weeks to go before ti
they took a gamble on eu's topmost son
fun fact he isn't the top son at all
he has 11 siblings 11
7 older four younger that's a lot of sex
anyway back then thompson was a super
fringe dude
he'd dropped out of culinary school to
pursue his dota career
and it reflected in his play he was
incredibly creative
which showed in his far from
conventional hero pool
a quality that drew criticism from some
of his peers
thompson is very obnoxious he's a weirdo
he's a very weird player
it's like what kind of mid player buys
meteor hammer on invoker and plays pogba
on monkey king like what's what's going
on you know
for most this was niche situational [ __ ]
but not for thompson this guy ran it all
day
every day and he didn't just mainline
cheesy [ __ ]
he dumpstered people with it there's the
setup
into the stun cold snap that's me just
leaves it it goes for the walk off kill
he knows that he's got it he didn't you
know that's
cool guys don't look at explosions while
thompson's in-game approach was
exuberant
it stood in stark contrast to the shy
and subdued way he carried himself
outside of game
thompson i learned quickly that he was
well
similar to other scandinavians maybe a
bit more reserved
needless to say going into the
international 8 which by the way was
thompson's first
actual land no one expected anything of
this frightful little fin
in addition to looking like he was
always in need of an adult
it honestly felt as if he was just happy
to be included
how did it feel coming into ti with that
track record
was it overconfidence was it the right
amount of confidence
talk to us about your mentality we were
constant of course
yeah i mean not overconfident for sure
but we
are good skilled team and we're gonna
beat every team here
here's the thing though they actually
[Applause]
did
[Applause]
that boy went toe to toe with the best
of the best and
more often than not conducted a master
class
in unorthodox ownage thompson is
actually sticking around has the sentry
advantage here
so it doesn't know what ami is up to
kind of looks like he's baiting at they
yeah you did do that he was baiting it
this man alive though he doesn't have
the black hole back up here banana with
a big gun sending him back
tornado thompson he's into the back of
the beater
coming down thompson with the saves gets
both for them
doing it big time on the main stage that
thompson he's actually got some
damage miss uphill is it gonna happen
noah doesn't the crepify
he just has to wait and with the blast
hobson
he has been an absolute genius terror
blade bt's forward the ball is up
thompson needs to defend x over very
visible you've got a very very low life
mirana but og they can't find the target
x nova he's got the grip he's got the
control he's got the kill thompson is
down but
yes it's up where the echoes slam
[Applause]
and thanks to his contribution the
tournament's biggest underdogs
rallied to become its unlikeliest
champions
the best part was that it felt like
thompson was as
dumbfounded with the whole thing as we
were thompson
three thousand dollars in your pocket
you come to tr you get an email from
notel you're a ti
champion what
to say that the community couldn't
believe it would be an understatement
of all the competitors ever to hoist the
aegis
none had literally come out of nowhere
the way thompson had
it was unprecedented and unthinkably
awesome
before ti8 no one knew or cared who tops
in was
but afterward dota fans across the world
worshiped him and you could see the
effect it was having on him
too he started growing out his hair
getting swole
and developing a sort of swagger i
stupid laura
all day long the only thing is that i
don't have to
like count my every euro i spend like i
can go shop i can buy food and i don't
have a care like
how much it costs like you know but it
wasn't until og
sauntered into ti9 as last year's
cinderella sensation
the things really ramped up they've
taken most of the year off to recuperate
and given that no single player had ever
amassed a second ti
no one expected lightning to strike
twice least of all
for thompson although i'm pretty sure
you can guess what happened next back to
the bases liquid have nothing
they have nothing to offer [ __ ] they're
just giving look at this they're diving
fountain and ti finals they want karaoke
in the fountain as well they're gonna
get it they're chasing miracles well
oh my god i can't believe this i can't
believe what we're seeing in this game
for
oh gee you thought you saw it on game
[Applause]
so how did ti's unlikeliest champion
become its first ever two-time
honestly by giving even fewer shits than
the previous year
ti8 saw thompson's idiosyncratic
playstyle get validation
on his game's biggest stage he showed up
to ti9
with even weirder and more
self-assertive [ __ ] to flex
but this time he rolled everybody with
it without hesitation
thompson he just does not give a crap
adam will give all the life
this is just fountain bombing defusal
gyrocopter wait what
diffuser gyrocopter tourette's defusal
gyrocopter
fancy that thompson doing something i
don't i don't think i've ever seen this
he's got three's available but he's
gonna burst and he's got the shield
and now they'll be able to turn
cooldowns dropped down by thompson
and here we have it beautiful this man
is gone he's able to pop the stick get
it
a fair bit of it back and he's here but
let's head back in pushing og
back behind the racks they're getting a
good amount of damage onto the c3 tower
liquid little push-ups
on io that spirit hero damage is there
now
going to join the freight finally there
we have it miracles mana it's pretty
much entirely gone by thompson's folks
he'll look forward
thompson focusing miracle miracles still
out of mana
because of his diffusion he's over the
cop of the ga is out we
will fall down the basic damage is there
from thompson miracles trying to run
another stick jackpot but jericho could
shut him off in fact jazz he's ready to
try and look for more potentially
there's only the ones
thompson he's on top of another cooldown
there that turns back into the combo
they're all getting picked apart as my
control falls
miracle is surrounded and they're all
dead
it's kind of fun when you like when
you're playing with your team and you
you know you're reading then you just
buy some random weird item and they're
like
why do you have this if you thought the
community was going buckwild over this
guy before
man his so-called 15 million defusal
was instantly recognized as one of the
ballsiest and biggest brain moves
in ti history and so the people
dubbed him godson thompson's god dude
that guy can do whatever he wants man
i actually don't give a [ __ ] but that
wasn't the only thing they called him
this isn't even his final form yet
you better be ready it's only coming
next year
you see in the months following ti9
thompson underwent yet another
transformation
fresh cut pierced ears he even lost the
glasses
he didn't just cement himself as a
champion for the ages
but as a literal chad i mean
just look at that drip manza's looking
like a whole damn snack
which is presumably how he became dadson
i'm gonna teach you how to play dora
i'm gonna be the best daughter player
don't i'm gonna tell you no don't play
dota there
gonna ruin your life it's becoming
increasingly common for esports to
afford their competitors the lives
they always dreamed of but in thompson's
case
it feels like it was expedited from
topsoil to flopsyn
to thompson to top god to godson
it got to the point where the community
was pretty much forced to create a super
saiyan chart
in his honor and sure he's had his share
of good fortune
but the truth is he's also just that
talented
underneath all of the memes surrounding
thompson's transmutation
is one of the most staggering stories of
success
and self-discovery that esports has ever
seen
he is a god in game and out
that guy is like the best player i've
seen in dota a long time
because he doesn't just play the game
like it's not even the stupid little
[ __ ] that he does it's just like how he
plays
he just creates pressure not the
pressure that people think what pressure
is it's like not mental pressure it's
like literally dota pressure he creates
builder pressure on the map
like he creates situations and there
aren't that many players that do it
so where does chadson go from here does
he
continue to ball out of control or does
he
quit while he's ahead and preserve his
100
ti win rate at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter
what he chooses to do since bursting
onto the scene
he's given dota fans reason to question
everything they thought they knew
about their sacred game thompson 100
ci win right here on this man
in a matter of two years thompson has
shown that you can successfully reach
the apex of competition
armed with a batshit imagination and
most importantly
a ton of self-belief and whichever
version of him you stan
whether it's thompson or godson the man
has proven himself to be
the biggest gangster dota's ever seen
and the scariest part is that
in spite of all the hunger and humility
now
he knows it yeah
[Music]
if you thought the community was going
buck wild over this guy
before man
i don't know why i tried i tried to
perfectly safe
and it destroyed me
buck wild buck wild into a
it's serious but yeah here we go